ich habe gerade 370 €men 100000 User
sind jetzt gerade live auf Twitch nur
die allerwenigsten haben wirklich krasse
Zuschauerzahlen das ist unter anderem
der Grund warum ich nach meinen Twitch
Livestreams meistens ziemlich kleine
Streamer supporte hey krass ich
boah was machst du heute werde ich
allerdings nicht meine Zuschauer nach
dem Beenden meines Streams zu einem
kleineren Streamer schicken sondern
ihnen Geld donaten und zwar insgesamt
1000 € ich würde sagen wir fangen an mit
ihm hier er spielt gerade city Skylines
und er hat gerade a Zuschauer wir fangen
bei ihm jetzt einfach mal an mit 20 €
und arbeiten uns dann über die Dauer des
Videos hoch FE deinen Stream mach weiter
soaserapete durch den Chat und schreibt
Feier dein Stream mach weiter so danke
das hab ich noch nie vom Bot gesehen
danke dir vom Bot ich bin kein bot ich
bin Luca er ist völlig perplex das denn
her womit habe ich das denn verdient
einfach so 20 € bist du verrückt Luca
vielen vielen Dank kein Problem
bedeutet ich würde ihm am liebsten alles
geben oh
m ach du heilige Scheiße oh Mann ich
habe mir 1000 € für das heutige Video
vorgenommen am liebsten W ich direkt
1000 donaten die Jungs hier schauen
glaube ich gerade zweite Liga und
streamen einfach wie sie das Gucken sein
top Donator ist Maki 08 mit 48 € das
überschreiten wir jetzt erstmal 50 € von
Laser Laca danke für die 50 €ön alles
Gute für Aufstieg der Laser gibt nur ein
laseraer 50
also wirklich danke noch kein Problem
Bruder 50€ viel Geld D Tage später viel
Glück für Aufstieg Jungs jetzt
kam hier donaten wir als nächstes und
zwar sammeln die beiden Geld und Spenden
für den Tierschutz Benutzer definierter
Betrag wir machen mal 80 € ich weiß halt
jetzt nicht ob die das im Stream
angezeigt bekommen und dann darauf
reagieren aber wir spenden einfach mal
das mein Name
84,6 für den Deutschen
Tierschutzbund bei mir
geradeer 8€ spendet was 80
€ das ist das mindeste für Tiere bitte
schön vielen vielen vielen Dank kein
Problem se seh gern wirklich ja kein
Problem ist immer cool solche Sachen zu
supporten ich supporte in Köln ja auch
einige tierschutzprojekte sie hier
spielt gerade GTA online und hat 29
Zuschauer wir spenden jetzt einfach mal
100 € ich macht das komplett ohne
Nachricht ich schreib einfach nichts
rein einfach komplett
kommentarlos
[Musik]
gut es kam sofort warte ganz kurz
B was ist den jetzt
passiert hst du das ich ich war das was
ist hier gerade passiert ich habe 100 €
donated ich muss mal ganz kurz was
nachdenken danke schön für fucking 100 €
W ist laserla es so lustig weil ich mit
meinem besten Freund immer mal über dich
Rede
und deswegen ist das gerade so random
ich dachte sie kennt mich nicht ich find
es aber auch wichtig kleinere Streamer
zu supporten ich meine sie hier hat
jetzt gerade 29 Zuschauer klar 29 leute
das ist ein ganzer Klassenraum voll also
wenn ich vor 29 Leuten stehen würde
würde ich mir echt in die Hosen pissen
aber ich finde gerade so auf Twitch oder
so Plattform wo es neue Creator halt
sehr schwierig haben macht Sinn kleinere
Creator zu supporten egal ob das jetzt
nach meinen Livestreams mit demem raate
ist also ich schick meine Leute rüber zu
kleineren Streamern oder jetzt hier halt
ein bisschen Geld machen wir nun
allerdings weiter mit 130 € die ich an
sie donaten werde sie spielt gerade
irgendwie so ein tierspiel ich schreibe
als Nachricht einfach mal Messi oder
Ronaldo mal schauen was S sagener Luca
danke für 130 € Messi oder Ronaldo oder
Ronaldo
was was z h ist
passiert gib nur eine
Antwort don't know Messi ich würde Messi
sagen so sehr gut die Frage ich habe
Fisch geworfen ich bin gespannt was sagt
wenn sie sieht dass ich 130 € donatet
habe weiß ja noch nicht wie viel ich
donatated habe ach du heilige
Scheiße
laserlukas beantworte lieber die Frage
dann sage ich Messi ja sehr gut okay
richtige Antwort bittte schön für die
130 € mach mal weiter dein hasenkampf da
Mo ist auch gerade live und bei ihm
schauen 20 Leute zu Mo ein Kumpel von
mir aus Köln ich donate ihm jetzt
einfach mal ein Fuffi so auf Lock bitte
mach deinen Stream
aus eine Stunde später Krieg mal hin ja
kriegst du auch mal hin die dono
vorzulesen auf zu pfeifen ma hier noch
mal hier Anwesenheitskontrolle
anwesenheitskrol Chat schreiben alle die
gerade gucken ja schreibe ich jetzt auch
l mal deine donus vor Laa was machst du
alter hast du was gespendet oder was ja
habe ich ich hab keine Dings an mir egal
Z gleich zurück 50 € ja mach bitte mach
dein Stream aus warum spendest du mir 50
€ schön ich habe nur subdings eingefügt
weil ich dachte mir spenden tut eh
keiner wer ich danke dir WER gefragt hat
du h
so als nächstes spenden wir 200 € an ihn
hier das ist ein alter Herr der hat
gerade vier Zuschauer und spielt
[Musik]
roblox
ich glaub er checkt nicht Laser Luca
weiß er wie viel das waren ach ja ach ja
200 € die bringen das Buch dann auch
raus er gesagt die bringen das für dich
raus die bringen das für dich raus die
drucken das und so und bringen das in
die Geschäfte ne jetzt unterhalten die
sich über Bücher also ich habe da
wirklich nichts Großes erwartet oder so
aber ich dachte halt dass man so ein
älteren Herrn wie ihm hier den OM oder
wie er heißt dass er zumindest irgendwie
dankbar ist er einfach nur einmal kurz
gesagt danke dir Bro um das ganze Video
jetzt allerdings abzuschließen und um
vor allem auf die 1000 € zu kommen
donate ich jetzt zu allerletzt 370 € an
die beiden hier die laufen gerade
irgendwie in real life rum und ich
erhoffe mir da einfach irgendwie eine
krassere Reaktion als bei dem Opa gerade
als Nachricht schreibe ich einfach wer
das si es doof ich glaub es hat noch nie
jemand 370 € Don mit soer dummen
Nachricht ich glaub sie
checkt was war das
geradeer drin
ja sie guckt wie so ein
Esel gerade gesehen ich hab gesehen
irgwas mit Paypal
ja Laser Luca wenn du hier bist danke
dir bitte hast du gesehen wie viel ich
habe gerade 370 € bekommen wieso spend
ich dir den to sie he Lua by the way sie
ist noch Single ach du scheiße
e ich war vorhin bei diesen Reisen und
autoaktivitäten weil ich mir dachte wenn
Leute unterwegs sind in public ist es
vielleicht ein bisschen spannender als
wenn Leute roblox zocken das vielleicht
gar nicht nebenbei
merken oh mein Gott danke schön so krass
ist das jetzt auch nicht das ist jetzt 2
Minuten Arbeiten du weißt gar nicht wie
dringt ich das Geld gerade brauche
deswegen kam so komplett unerwartet aber
wow
wow ich bin sprachlos hab bekommen ist
sehr selten bei
mir ich bin gerade kurz
V ja okay krass Freunde an der stelle
ich das heutige Video jetzt auch beenden
wenn ihr auch mal von mir Geld Don
bekommen wollt dann abonniert meinen
Kanal und keine ahnunger ich muss so
kacken die ganze Zeit schon danke ganz
liebe ich es dir gut geht ich ich Bert
bin
[Musik]
oh bisschen Hitzewallung